President Trump has been in England you  all know this he's been in England to  commemorate the 75th anniversary of  d-day yeah and there's been some ups and  downs yeah I think it's fair to say  reporters are pointing out that  President Trump made a bit of a faux pas  by touching the Queen's back you're not  supposed to do that yeah after being  touched by Trump the Queen immediately  summoned the Duke of purell was a Duke  by the way you guys are amazing on that  set up to that joke oh they're like  professionals  their royal watch watch Oh  one doesn't do that hey Prince Harry's  wife Megan Marco was able to avoid  meeting President Trump because she's on  maternity leave so she got to avoid him  yeah so today today today when Trump  said he'd like to come back Queen  Elizabeth announced she's pregnant  and she said she will be for the metal  be writing it for two years yeah yeah  show Trump's turns over yeah